hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña mauro está magno el es médico
cirujano de tórax oriundo de la ciudad
de rosario en argentina pero está
radicado actualmente en sao paulo brasil
donde trabaja en cuatro hospitales
privados ya ha operado a decenas de
pacientes con kobe 19 un testimonio en
primera persona sobre cómo es ser médico
y trabajar todos los días enfrentando la
pandemia de coronavirus en el segundo
país más afectado de todo el mundo mauro
tan magno muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
hola muchas gracias y por favor en
primer lugar a mauro preguntarte cómo es
ser médico y tratar pacientes con kobe
19 en el que es el segundo país más
afectado del mundo por la pandemia no
cómo se viven estas nuevas jornadas de
atención en este contexto tan crítico
bueno mira al principio como comenté en
otras en otras oportunidades era una
cosa nueva de ser una bomba atómica
porque explotaba no explotó en nuestra
cara no sabíamos cómo tener estos tipos
de pacientes no tenemos un tratamiento
efectivo padrón para esa enfermedad no
tenemos cómo prevenirlo a través de una
vacuna y hace meses atrás es ver tantos
pacientes al mismo tiempo con la misma
enfermedad
fue un shock tener una cosa que
impensada en todos estos años de
medicina que cuando estudiaba y después
cuando empecé a trabajar nunca pensé que
iba a pasar por una situación similar un
shock
visto a la distancia cómo evaluás todos
estos meses transitado no hasta llegar a
la situación actual con la expansión del
virus en brasil
primero fuimos aprendiendo
a entender como todo este virus no es
cierto al principio todo no solamente
los médicos sino también parte de los
políticos de la gente
de salud
no no no no creíamos que iba a ser de
tal magnitud estábamos por lo que
escuchábamos organizaciones
internacionales por los países los
primeros países que fueron afectados
pensábamos que era una cosa más leve y
que no iba a llegar a la magnitud que
llegó entonces tuvimos que ir
aprendiendo día a día
a convivir con el virus una cosa que
desde el principio desde cuando empezó
el primer después del primer mes de
estoy viviendo la cantidad de pacientes
yo decía esto no no vino esto vino para
quedarse no es una cosa pasajera
perdón que te interrumpí te quería
consultar en qué estado se encuentra el
sistema sanitario brasileño no tanto a
nivel público como privado que es el
sector en el que trabajamos no teniendo
en cuenta como dije al comienzo de la
entrevista que estamos hablando del
segundo país más afectado de todo el
mundo
el sistema privado no colapsó
principalmente a que en san paolo que
fue el epicentro de brasil en la ciudad
del estado con mayor población y con
mayor movimiento económico del país
la capital de la parte privada no tuvo
ningún tipo de
de problema no es cierto ahora llegamos
a ocupación de 80 90 por ciento y
en el pico no cierto de la de la
enfermedad
en la parte pública se realizaron se
abrieron cuatro hospitales de campaña
aquí en el estado en san pablo y
y después paulatinamente se fueron
cerrando porque nos llegaron a ser
ocupados en una totalidad entonces en
medio del estado trabajamos con un 80
por ciento de ocupación 90 por ciento
pero nunca llegó a haber un colapso del
sistema
ahora brasil tiene también altas cifras
de profesionales de la salud contagiados
vosotros lo viviste en carne propia no
el primer encuentro con el virus fue por
supuesto en el hospital donde trabajas
pero luego llegó a tu familia vos tu
esposa y también tu hija se contagiaron
como vivieron toda esa etapa
fue un shock balde de agua fría porque
yo trabajaba en el hospital desde el
principio
empezar a ver aparte eso es parte del
grupo de kobe para enfrentar la pandemia
al principio en un cierto
yo le pedí a mi familia saliera del
departamento porque por mi especialidad
estaba seguro que me iba a contagiar no
sé si no me preguntaba si viva o no me
iba a contagiar sino cuando me iba a
contagiar entonces estuvimos separado
casi un mes con mi esposa mi hija y
después de un mes y ver como le había
dicho que esto no no venía para de
pasada sino que venía para quedarse
ellos volvieron a casa y una semana
después de ella estarán ellos estar acá
mi hija que tiene un año y dos meses
tuvo una convulsión febril él precisó
ser internada en terapia intensiva
estuvo 24 horas en observación como
donde el análisis tanto de licor como de
la parte neurológica se llega al
diagnóstico de coronavirus ahí yo fui
positivo y tres días después mi esposa
también entonces ahí están los dos lados
de la moneda con cierto por un lado
haciendo preparando el hospital para
enfrentar esto y después esa bomba que
explotó en tu casa entonces en mi esposa
no es médica y cuando le dieron el
diagnóstico de que aquí tenía
coronavirus desarrollada decía yo no me
quiero morir no es la sensación de final
de vida en cierto
ahora tengamos momento de temas buenos
no de tema no pero vamos un poquito más
al área también de la gestión no en
brasil- de la pandemia el presidente ya
ir bolsonaro ha generado muchísimas
polémicas y críticas precisamente como
te decía por su manejo de la crisis
sanitaria la llamado gripe sin ya dijo
que se estaba sobredimensionado en un
momento al poder destructivo que él no
ha respetado en algunas ocasiones normas
de bioseguridad incluso luego de haber
dado positivo no por kobe 19 hubo
también hay muchos movimientos políticos
dos ministros de salud dejaron sus
cargos en medio de la crisis y de
polémica con bolsonaro usted como
profesional de la salud mauro qué
lectura hace de esa gestión de la crisis
que realiza el presidente bolsonaro y
qué impacto cree que puede tener en la
manera en que el virus se propagó en el
país
no creo que en todos los países se
politice solo me parece una cosa
lamentable se colocó por delante del
problema de la populación intereses
personales políticos tanto como del
presidente como de la oposición a ver
quién sacaba una ventaja de esto y se
olvidaron de la gente entonces se
tomaron algunas medidas que tanto desde
el punto de vista nacional como estadual
del estado de san pablo
me parece que eso perjudicó
cuando recibimos las primeras
informaciones de coronavirus en enero en
la principal fiesta de brasil que es el
carnaval se debería haber cancelado y
por parte de los gobernadores usted dijo
que no
si presidente ironizó hablando de que
era una magra decía al comienzo cuando
uno de los médicos referentes del
gobierno de san pablo dijo eso entonces
me parece que desde el primer del primer
momento se subestimó y se politizó y eso
se llevó a que se olvidaron un poco más
de la populación y se quedaron con
intereses políticos y que perdió perdido
todos por todos perdimos perdimos la
populación la gente los médicos el país
los países me parece que se podrían
haber evitado algunas algunas
circunstancias si se hubiese tomado otro
tipo de actitud no en cuenta la cantidad
de pacientes que se ha visto y además
por supuesto por el solo hecho de vivir
en sao paulo que están en contacto con
los ciudadanos qué percepción cree que
hay en general en la sociedad sobre el
virus y su comportamiento no en términos
de prevención de cuidados
cree que de alguna manera se subestimó
al virus en brásil
se subestimó principalmente en la
población hacia la parte central de la
capital lo que nosotros nos damos cuenta
es que la parte del centro de san
pablo-t respeto mucho lo que es la
cuarentena el aislamiento social lo que
es la parte periférica de las ciudades
donde lamentablemente en la situación
económica
no es buena donde hay poco ingreso de
dinero y que precisa trabajar el día a
día no se respetó tanto la cuarentena
por una necesidad económica y por parte
también de mucha gente no creía que el
vivirse existía o que tenía el poder de
letalidad la magnitud de contagio y
nosotros vemos el número de enfermos con
el número de muertos
podemos decir fríamente que es una
enfermedad que no tiene una tasa de
letalidad tan grande
el virus que se contagia muy fácilmente
y muy rápido y lo que lleva el colapse
existen en salud entonces la gente se
subestimó desde un principio lo que
podría lo que podría acontecer con ese
virus porque parecía que no existe que
es la mentira que estaban exagerando que
no era así y por la situación económica
personal de cada lugar se llevó no
respetar la cuarentena
ha hecho ustedes mauro que vio algunos
médicos que se han negado a atender a
pacientes por miedo a que atribuye estas
actitudes había visto algo así antes
no la verdad que no me parece que es
también por parte del desconocimiento y
el miedo eso fue en los primeros días
cuando las terapias intensivas empezaron
a llenarse de pacientes
había colegas que tenían que hacer
alguna cirugía intervención menor como
accesos periféricos vasculares que no se
negaban a atenderlos porque tenían miedo
de contagiar el contagiar a la familia
nosotros muchos médicos decidieron al
estar separados de la familia de los
cinco de los padres hasta ahora tengo
colegas que hace meses que nos ven a los
padres que no tienen contacto
personal sino a través de redes sociales
oa través de aplicativos de videollamada
mauro está magno te agradecemos
muchísimo su presencia en la entrevista
de frank 24 ha sido un placer dialogar
contigo
como muchas gracias a ustedes por esta
oportunidad y espero que podamos
recuperarnos rápidos todo de esto y que
espero que lo peor se haya pasado
ojalá que así sea compartimos el mismo
deseo mauro a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y recuerden que pueden
volver a ver esta entrevista y muchas
otras en france24 punto com
[Música]